well Sean Boswell may not have left an
enormous stamp on the past and Furious
franchise his own story in the past and
the Furious Tokyo Drift is actually
pretty packed
from juvenile delinquency to being
crowned Tokyo's newest drift King here's
Sean's Fast and Furious backstory
explained growing up Sean Boswell never
stayed in one place for very long his
parents divorced when he was three years
old and his father a U.S Navy officer
eventually left the country for a
position in Tokyo Japan back in the
States Sean and his mother moved
frequently often due to Young Sean's
Reckless or criminal Behavior their
roots are in Alabama but by the time the
audience first meets Sean at the start
of Tokyo Drift he's attending a high
school in Arizona his third town in only
two years at 17 Sean is a loner
interested in only one thing driving we
don't know where this love affair with
cars begins but we do know that he takes
the driving and street racing pretty
quickly sean gets a speeding ticket on
his first day as a licensed driver and
handedly wins his first race the day
after that Sean finds a sense of common
control in the act of driving but it
only makes his life more chaotic he gets
two arrests on his record before Tokyo
Drift even starts however since he and
his mother leave town every time he
screws up Sean is used to escape keeping
long-term consequences for his actions
as a result he doesn't seem to care much
about the destruction he causes
one afternoon after school Sean finds
himself chatting with his classmate
Cindy much to the irritation of Cindy's
football star boyfriend Clay after some
teasing from Sean clay throws a baseball
through the window of Sean's prize 1971
Chevy Monte Carlo Cindy who clearly gets
a kick out of plane with her boyfriend's
insecurities suggests that clay and Sean
settle their dispute in a street race
putting herself up his surprise the two
drivers raced through a construction
site for an upscale Suburban Housing
Development falling behind in the race
Sean attempts to take a shortcut through
one of the half-built houses this puts
him neck and neck with clay and Cindy
and helps him get to the Finish Line
first but Clay's aggressive driving ends
up sending both cars out of control and
all three participants are injured
after the construction site debacle the
police threatened Sean with some serious
charges that could finally stick however
Sean's mother manages to arrange one
last reprieve by sending him off to
Tokyo to live with his father major
Boswell sets a few strict but Simple
Rules were Sean to live by go to school
come right home and no driving but said
Sean has never been inclined to follow
rules he gets involved in the Tokyo
street racing scene right away when
major Boswell learns that Sean has
disobeyed him he initially threatens to
have him sent back to the U.S but then
the major decides to give Sean one last
chance and the subject of Sean break in
their Arrangement is never brought up
again
Sean doesn't have to work very hard to
find his crowd in Tokyo the first person
to befriend him at school is Twinkie an
American Army brat who knows about a
race happening that very night Twinkie
takes Sean to a multi-level parking
structure where Young Drivers race to
the top executing precise drifts to turn
tight Corners there he encounters
another of his classmates Nila and
doesn't waste any time in beginning to
flirt but once again he butts heads with
a jealous boyfriend Nila is involved
with Takashi who earned his nickname DK
short for drift King for being the best
racer on the circuit Having learned
nothing from his last disastrous race in
Arizona the foolish and headstrong Sean
challenges Takashi to a race eager for
the chance to embarrass the American
teen Takashi accepts but there are two
problems Shawn has neither a car to race
with nor the first idea of how drifting
Works takashi's friend the enigmatic
Hans solves the first problem offering
up his own highly modified Nissan Silvia
S15 on a lark the second tower reproves
insurmountable Twinkie tries to quickly
explain drifting to Sean but to no avail
Shawn winds up humiliating him all been
doing thousands of dollars worth of
damage to Hans Nissan on upon seeing how
thoroughly Sean has trashed this car has
just three parting words for Sean
don't leave town Sean is now heavily
indebted to Han who we get to know much
better in future Fast and Furious films
in order to work off his dad Sean begins
working for Han doing whatever the more
established racer asks Han runs a garage
and has vaguely defined connections to
organized crime though Sean is insulated
from the details of his business John
only needs to concern himself with
pickups and deliveries and answering the
phone whenever Han calls these are rules
Sean has no trouble following he begins
spending more and more of his Time with
Han going so far as to move out of his
father's apartment and into a bunk at
haunt's garage Han is genuinely fond of
Sean and has no hard feelings over the
wrecked Nissan in fact Hans sees the
loss of one car as a bargain in exchange
for getting to know someone's character
the two develop a close relationship as
Han teaches Sean that there's more to
life than just racing but of course this
being a fast and furious movie racing is
still important while American street
racing came very naturally to Sean he
doesn't hold a candle to the skilled
Tokyo Drifters Han agrees to teach Sean
how to drift so they can have a chance
at a rematch against Takashi having to
essentially start from scratch and
really work at something seems to teach
Sean some much needed discipline and the
training pays off as Sean wins his
return race against takashi's Lieutenant
Morimoto
it's easy to get the impression that
it's been years since Sean was in any
one place long enough to make friends it
seems as though he's long since given up
on the idea of getting attached to
people upon arriving in Tokyo Shaun is
disinterested in talking to anyone since
he assumes that he'll be sent back to
the U.S soon but is this day in Tokyo
lasts longer than he imagined Sean
begins to make real connections to some
of his peers especially Twinkie back in
Arizona Sean once turned a blind eye to
another kid being bullied but he makes a
point of standing up her Twinkie when
he's attacked at school while Twinkie
berates Sean for his interference it
still shows significant growth from
where he was prior to coming to Tokyo
Sean also spends time sharing in
Twinkies interests accompanying him on
one of his sales excursions on the
streets of Tokyo later when Sean spewed
with Takashi becomes a life and death
struggle Twinkie gives Sean all of his
savings to help Sean resolve things
peacefully if not for this act of
friendship it's unlikely that Sean would
have survived to the end of Tokyo Drift
Sean also steadily matures in his
interactions with Nila his early
flirtations are swiftly rebuffed but
soon he begins to make the effort to
actually get to know her on her own
terms gradually the two become real
friends Shawn and Nila Bond over their
shared love of cars and drift racing but
also their Mutual status as Outsiders in
Japanese Society despite being born in
Japan neela carries the stigma of being
the child of an Australian immigrant
utakashi implies was a sex worker after
her mother's death Nila was taken in by
the Yakuza Affiliated kamada Family but
despite being raised alongside Takashi
she's never treated as if she truly
belongs even Takashi treats Nila more
like a possession than a person Shawn
and nila's relationship doesn't go
unnoticed by Takashi who beats up Sean
as a warning to stay away from his
girlfriend this is the last straw for
Nila who finds the courage to leave
Takashi and take shelter at Han's garage
by his own admission one of the reasons
Han likes keeping Sean around is to
annoy his business partner Takashi while
Takashi is the better connected of the
two hana's older and more shrewd as it
turns out Han may also be using Sean to
divert takashi's attention from a far
more serious betrayal Han has been
stealing from the commission owed to
kamada humiliating Takashi in the eyes
of his uncle Takashi comes to Han's
garage seeking revenge and is further
enraged to see that Nila and Sean are
both living there the three of them flee
the scene on in one car Sean and Nila in
another they're pursued individually by
Takashi and his friend Morimoto and
high-speed City chase when Takashi is
neck and neck with Sean and Nila and
attempts to nudge them off the road Han
drops back and puts his own car between
them this helps get Sean and neela out
of danger but it puts Han in the path of
oncom traffic out of nowhere he is
T-boned by another uninvolved vehicle
and is apparently killed in the ensuing
explosion later in Fast and Furious 6 we
learned that the accident was really
attempted murder By Deckard Shaw and in
F9 we see that Han actually survived
some now
after Han supposed death Sean no longer
has any protection from Takashi who
still wants him dead Sean's father
offers to send him back to the United
States to escape takashi's Vengeance but
Sean refuses he feels responsible for
the mess he's in and his days of running
away from his problems are over instead
he throws himself at the mercy of
takashi's Uncle kamada apologizing in
person for Han's deception and offering
a non-violent resolution to his conflict
with Takashi
race
and the loser leaves town for good the
Absurd suggestion seems to amuse kamana
and the challenge is accepted with his
own car damaged in the Chase and the
rest of Han's cars seized by the police
Sean once again finds himself without a
ride for his race against the drift King
all that's left in Han's garage is the
wreck of the Nissan that Sean used in
his ill-fated drift racing debuted Shawn
Twinkie and the rest of Han's pit crew
joined forces to combine the high
performance parts from Hans Nissan with
a chassis of a Vintage Mustang belonging
to Sean's dad creating a new ride that's
both American and Japanese
following a high-speed race down a
precarious winding Mountainside Road
Sean crosses the Finish Line first
winning his and nila's freedom in the
title of drift King
at the end of The Fast and the Furious
Tokyo Drift Sean has paid a visit by
main franchise protagonist Dominic
Toretto who challenges him to a race in
honor of their mutual friend Han later
Furious 7 explains that this encounter
wasn't simply the result of a friendly
visit rather Dom traveled to Tokyo while
on the trail of Han's killer Deckard
Shaw
the events of Furious 7 brought toredo's
team into the retcon timeline that's all
Tokyo Drift occurring after the events
of Fast and Furious 6. the guys in Japan
weren't heard from again until F9 found
them on another continent altogether by
then Sean and his buddies Twinkie and
Earl have moved to Germany where they
now build specialty cars for the
government Toronto's team is doing their
own secret government work these days
usually for a character named Mr Nobody
the leader of a very hush-hush covert
Ops organization Dom's latest Mission
has to do with stopping Cypher from
overtaking the world with the universal
hacking device called project Aries and
Dom sends tej and Roman to recruit the
German Outpost to their cause there is
of course no mention of the romance Sean
had back in Tokyo Drift But there have
legitimately been a couple years between
then and now even on this convoluted
timeline so a breakup is reasonable plus
it's safe to assume that if he moved
full-time to Germany he wasn't still
with Nila watching Sean's crew at work
is kind of like asking the question what
if jackass existed in the cars Universe
when Roman and tej arrive in Germany
Sean Twinkie and Earl are strapping
high-powered rocket engines to the roofs
of Pontiac Fieros sporty two-seaters
built between 1984 and 1988 that looked
like Matchbox cars the purpose of this
firecracker experiment is apparently to
race jet planes the guys are generally
thrilled if their sacrificial Fiero
neither blows up nor melts at the end so
that says all there is to say about how
successful they are still Roman and tez
are there specifically for some wheels
at Dom's request and they intend to
procure some
for reasons too convoluted to list tejan
Roman must get into close physical
contact with an orbiting satellite in
order for Ramsay to prevent the
universal hacking program project Aries
from taking over the world once uploaded
luckily they just so happen to know a
few guys working with rockets soon Sean
and Earl are piling in a giant plane
into the stratosphere with a
rocket-powered Pontiac Fiero strapped on
top where it will then have to make
contact with a satellite 50 miles above
the Earth's surface while in that
Perpetual Free Fall known as orbit sure
Earl still running launch simulations on
his iPad but they're at least mostly
certain that the DIY astronauts will be
safe soon the Fiero has broken through
the atmosphere with tejan Roman along
for the ride now the Tejas Math and
Science has brought them this far Romans
in charge numbers is what you do right
driving is what I do after all is said
and done Dom throws a family cookout
back at his place in Los Angeles and now
the family includes Earl Twinkie and
Sean family has always been a theme for
the franchise and a driving force for
Dom in particular the men and women the
crew are his Brethren so it's fitting
that when Han comes around the corner
and sees Sean grabbing beers with the
rest of the Tokyo gang the two Embrace
like long-lost brothers Han introduces
the guys to L who has been his Ward
since her parents were killed and Sean
hugs her too everyone mingles about and
the camera jumps from group to group to
check in on how everyone is doing and
that's pretty much it for Sean Boswell
thus far
[Music]